hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
were back on foreign again today's
Thursday it steps to recap date you
already know what's going on that a huge
debt dev Q&A session that they talked
about for loads of questions so we're
gonna be going into that as well as
looking at the April roadmap but then we
also figured out that there's some
double xp in there and as well with the
release date or the reveal for the new
character is going to be so as always
like the V if you do enjoy my discord
and Twitter will be in the description
if you guys want to check those out and
join those and with that let's get
started
so we're gonna be going over the Q&A
first some of the more notable questions
is that the art team is planning on
updating the player expression like
tweaking the armor showing more pieces
of armor having more so that that
customization where like you can have
the silver embossing or like the gold
type of color plating I can show a lot
more in different places so a lot more
stuff with that they're currently
working on doing it for Berserker but
once they finish up with Berserker
they're gonna be going through the whole
cast and hopefully we'll have an entire
roster full of differently looking armor
so that would be always cool to see in
terms of the customization I talked
about before they're also focusing on
more outfits like I said in terms of
where to put more different pieces of
armor aren't already set pieces of armor
in the game but for the Viking
characters in specific they're also
going to be looking into giving us more
tattoos so if you do play a Viking hero
you might get some more higher-quality
more tattoos to be able to put on the
character cuz I don't remember the last
time I played a Viking hero but so
someone let me know in the comments
below but as I can remember we really
didn't get too many big and cool-looking
tattoos for the armors that they get so
just let me know what that the art team
is also looking into taking lots of the
neutral color palette colors and putting
them in the attacker and defender spots
respectively so we can have a lot more
colors to choose from I always am a big
fan of having more colors to choose from
but personally to me I feel like we
should just get rid of the attacking and
defending and just have an entire color
palette of colors but that's personally
just me in terms of arcade the
developers plan on making different
changes like new modes and new modifiers
to spice up the arcade mode the recent
event that we had actually had a quest
if you remember that had us able
actually surviving instead of killing
them so they're gonna be trying out new
features and new modifiers and hopefully
adding them into the future which will
be really cool and arcade is also
planning on being balanced next season
in season 10 one thought is that they
have it so that when you complete a
quest you're going to be receiving more
like the elite outfits that you should
only get from arcade as well as the
ornaments as well and a lot more steel
and XP from doing these which is really
nice to see there's also a fix coming in
season 10 that has to do with the
general characters and they're gonna be
trying to fix the very fast moving
attacks like shamans jump attacks and
valiant breakthrough for warden among
many others as well which caused the
opponent or you to phase through the
person that you're locking on to
allowing you to basically miss the
entire hit I've had that happen to me a
lot of times I'm shamans not really too
much on warden but it is definitely a
nice fix and hopefully that will be
coming very quickly in season 10 another
patch coming in season 10 probably
around the same time for these
fast-forward moves is there going to be
fixing some dodge rolling and unlocking
to avoid those mix ups and combos
they're gonna start tweaking this a
little bit more to definitely fine-tune
this type of strategy where you would
dodge rollout of a combo or you would
unlock and run away and come back I'm
gonna start trying to fine-tune this it
get it at its perfect spot and then
lastly the devs also have no plans of
making reflex guard characters aka the
assassins have a static guard like Ken
Sayer Raider that's going to be their
own thing and they're of course going to
keep the reflex guard but they are still
working on making shinobi and especially
gladiators guard to be up to par with
everyone else in the assassin list this
is most likely probably going to be a
season 10 patch I don't I don't see it
coming any time in season 9 but as long
as it comes I'm still happy for it next
up we have the April Road map the usual
event orders and the arcade modes are
going to be there but more notable is
that there's going to be double xp on
April 12th so if you have a new
character you want to test out and get
some armor for or if you want to grind a
rep 70 with a current hero that you have
definitely take advantage of the double
xp on April 12th what they're also being
a secret event playlist on April 12th as
well we don't actually know what it is
but I'm assuming it's going to be some
type of old game mode that we are
probably getting from the past so this
could be carousel of death dance a death
something like that or it could be
something completely different I have no
clue but I'm definitely interested to
see and on April 25th is the reveal for
season 10 or season 2 of year 3 whatever
you want to call that so lots of info
are gonna be mentioned about the new
samurai hero and what he / year is gonna
entail
I'm very hyped for it and I hope you are
too let me know your thoughts on that
and I will definitely be sure to recap
this whole stream for you guys when I
get the chance so do not worry about
that but what that guys like the video
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
like I said I come for the informational
side of foreigner that being the balance
changes and the hero updates and the
patch notes and leaks so we want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
lumineer thoughts on the new cut
let me know your thoughts in the April
roadmap in the comments below floats
inner thoughts and with that my two most
recent videos gonna be popping up on
screen and a bit if you guys want to
check that out and that have a great
rest your day and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]